♪♪
(Sheila)
Get a good look, honey?
Allow me to present the titular
body, behind Body By Sheila.
That is a dynamite looking
outfit.
What's that color?
Yellow.
(Sheila)
Eyes on the prize.
♪♪
I would love to expand into
my own lifestyle brand.
Stick to the plan.
♪♪
I want you to go out there and
promote your film.
It's a video tape.
Whatever it is.
(Sheila)
He doesn't care.
♪♪
I'm the original "her".
-You stole from me.
-No.
This is my routine.
-Tell them!
-Woah, woah, woah woah, woah.
What did we say about that anger
of yours?
That it's bad vibes.
Super bad vibes!
♪♪
I am committed to growing my
business.
You have a following.
But I don't have this.
♪♪
Are you marching?
Are you breathing?
Yeah!
I control my own name.
I control my own business,
and nobody tells me what to do
or say.
Greta, would you want to go into
business with me?
I just have one condition.
No more secrets?
♪♪
What secrets?
She took everything.
♪♪
Then let's take it back.
Change is coming.
♪♪
Growth.
(Glasses clink)
But so is loss,
♪♪
pain,
regret.
This isn't gonna work, Sheila.
It's non of your business.
It's actually half my business.
Five, six, seven, eight.
♪♪
What kind of person thinks they
can behave in this way?
♪♪
Are you here to work for me or
to try to become me?
♪♪
Sheila's rocket ship is about to
take off.
♪♪
I'm tired of playing defense.
So what's your goal?
♪♪
Reciprocity
or retribution?
♪♪
Annihilation.
Have we been in too long?
I'm starting to worry.
Oh relax, I mean you think
they'd sell these things if
they weren't safe?
Yeah that makes sense.